[Music]
on a Sunday night from Washington D.C
the final push in high-stakes elections
the razor thin races that could shift
the balance of power
but the power of America is in your
hands the Democrats warnings about
democracy plus why what happens in these
midterms matters to Canada
plus access to abortion in America I'm
gonna pay for it because it's
unconscionable doctors going to
extraordinary lengths to preserve
Reproductive Rights
a record-breaking report heating up the
start of the U.N climate change Summit
and energy terrorism Russia accused of
trying to freeze Ukraine into submission
this could lead to cities going dark in
Ukraine the bitter cold warning as
winter approaches
global national with Donna
Donna I look at America reasserted
itself around the world and lead the
world of 21st century there is no quit
in America we just have to remember who
we are we are the United States of
America if you support the decline and
fall of America then you must vote for
the radical left Democrats it kind of
slash and burn
politics that we're seeing right now
that doesn't have to be who we are it's
about fundamental values values I grew
up with values you grew up with values
we try to teach our kids values we learn
in churches and mosques and synagogues
and temples honesty fairness opportunity
hard work
a sitting president and two former
presidents making impassioned appeals to
Americans just two days ahead of a
crucial vote good evening and thanks for
joining us we are in Washington D.C
tonight ahead of a big political moment
in this country Americans are voting in
midterm elections this week 250 million
people are eligible to cast a ballot the
results will determine the makeup of the
U.S Congress and set the tone for the
next two years of President Joe Biden's
presidency Biden's name is not on the
ballot but his party's vision for
America is Biden's approval rating has
sunk since he got elected it now sits at
about 44 percent depending on which poll
you look at that is not unusual a
president's approval rating often drops
after two years in office but
historically that translates into a loss
of seats in Congress and right now the
Democrats can't afford to lose any
here's the situation Democrats control
both the House of Representatives and
the Senate but by narrow margins
Republicans can retake the house by
flipping just five seats and in the
Senate they need to flip just one seat
to gain control and take the gavel away
from Nancy Pelosi with me is Jackson
prosco our Washington bureau chief
Jackson Democrats say that democracy is
on the ballot in this election the
Republicans say it's all about the
economy where are things headed on
Tuesday I don't think anybody knows at
this point and that is what is so
remarkable as you mentioned this should
be a cakewalk for the party not in power
in this case Republicans but it's not
those messages about the fate of
democracy Donald Trump's continued
presence in the race all those things
have really been dragging down
Republicans at a time when the wind
should be blowing in their favor because
of Biden's unpopularity and what's going
on with the economy and inflation right
now so expect a lot of surprises both in
Congressional races and gubernatorial
races uh also I think expect that we
don't we may not necessarily know of
course the winners of some of those
races for quite some time so really
Donna you you get the picture you get
the sense that anyone making predictions
right now is going out on a limb because
it's very very hard to know how this is
going to shake down on Tuesday and
Jackson there are lots of Republicans
running for office who we know are
repeating the lie that the presidential
election in 2020 was stolen there are
concerns some of the candidates might
not accept the results of this election
yeah that is a very realistic concern
here what's been interesting sort of
over the past few weeks is how many of
these Republicans have tried to back
away from Trump's lie about the 2020
election they don't want to talk about
it they don't want to be seen as looking
in the rear view mirror but in reality
it's a big part of their campaign and I
don't think we know who's going to
accept the results and who's going to
contest them until we get to that point
but we should point out that former
president Trump and his legal team are
already talking about how they might
contest some of these races specifically
in Pennsylvania because they see that as
a trial run for what they might do in
2024. okay the midterms are on Tuesday
but we know that there was lots of early
voting lots of mail-in ballots when are
we going to know the results yeah 40
million Americans have already voted in
early voting the problem though is that
many of these states like Pennsylvania
do not allow the early processing of
those mail-in ballots so that slows
things down expect sort of a repeat of
2020 where we're waiting days maybe even
weeks for results and in the senate in
Georgia in particular that race is so
close we could be back in a situation
where it's a runoff in December and that
might actually decide control of the
Senate so we might be waiting for quite
some time here all right Jackson prosco
thanks we will come back to you in the
days ahead thanks
well Canadians always watch our neighbor
closely of course and if these midterms
result in the Democrats losing control
of the house and the Senate there will
almost certainly be an impact on
Canada's relationship with the U.S our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken is in Canada's capital tonight
David
well Donna U.S elections are always a
big deal to America's Northern neighbor
but this one it may be especially
important lots of things that would be
good for Canada if the Congress can
become a bit more functional the biggest
concern for Canada will be to protect
its trading relationship with the U.S
and push back on any protectionist
Tendencies from new members of Congress
and that protectionist push is as likely
to come from Rookie Democrats as it is
rookie Republicans Canada is going to
have to engage in
diplomacy and that's the private sector
and the public sector and Civil Society
um with the new congress with the new
Power Players to explain why Canada is
relevant to the United States I think
it's actually a huge opportunity for
Canada something that we can't forget is
that the U.S has really stalled making a
generational transition in government
and that shift could move influence away
from 80 year old Mitch McConnell 82 year
old Nancy Pelosi 79 year old Joe Biden
to leaders in their 30s and 40s what
many of us have been hoping for is for a
younger generation to come into
leadership and they will in this
Congress if in fact a republican tinge
Congress emerges there will be concerns
about the U.S watering down support for
Ukraine that's according to Canadian
David Frum who once worked in the George
W bush White House the Republicans will
bring with them a an important minority
especially in the house that is opposed
to supporting Ukraine and its fights for
Independence against Russia and then
there's climate change it would be
almost impossible for Canada to impose
new rules to cut greenhouse gas
Emissions on domestic Industries think
emission reduction requirements for cars
for example if the United States was not
doing the same that doesn't mean
we care about climate
crime senators
and disses and that sort of thing when
Donald Trump was President the Trudeau
government had to spend an inordinate
amount of energy and diplomatic
resources managing the U.S Canada
relationship sometimes at the expense of
other International relationships and
there was every expectation in this town
that a trump flavored Congress now will
need renewed attention from Canada's
politicians and diplomats Donna
okay David Aiken and Ottawa thanks
Reproductive Rights and access to
abortion is an issue in these midterms
but at least according to the polls it's
not the top of Mind issue it was back in
June that's when the U.S Supreme Court
overturned The Landmark ruling Roe
versus Wade that decision angered
millions of Americans the Democrats hope
to capitalize on that anger but it's now
November and public opinion polls show
the economy and inflation have eclipsed
abortion as the top issue Fara Nasser is
in Toronto she has more on that and the
rest of the day's news Farah thanks
Donna I was recently in the U.S and
medical providers I met there are hoping
the pollsters have missed out on the
millions of American women motivated to
vote on this single issue abortion has
always been a hot election topic even
here in Canada but this is the first
election in post-row America and
abortion Advocates are confident that
the raw Anger from this summer hasn't
fizzled out first let's have a look at
how the U.S has changed after Roe versus
Wade was overturned immediately
following the Supreme Court's decision
abortion bans in Alabama Arkansas
Kentucky Louisiana Missouri Oklahoma
South Dakota Utah and Wisconsin went
into effect anyone seeking performing or
helping with access to abortion now
faces severe consequences
the reversal led to mass protests across
the country and has been used as
campaign strategy by both Democrats and
Republicans to win over voters in this
year's midterm elections if Republicans
get their way with a national ban it
won't matter where you live in America
there should not be involvement from the
federal government and how States decide
their abortion decisions that a
patient's room is too narrow and small
and cramped of space for a woman her
doctor and the United States government
today we want to take you to the state
of Illinois an abortion access Island
mostly surrounded by states where
abortion is illegal or severely
restricted doctors from those bordering
areas are now tasting taking drastic
measures and finding creative ways to
protect women's Reproductive Rights
the nurses and doctors of Wisconsin
fighting to provide a service they can
no longer perform to sit in an exam room
with a patient who needs something that
I can't get for her is infuriating Dr
Kristen lyerly now works mostly in
advocacy after a Wisconsin ban on
abortion dating back to 1849 came back
into effect after Roe vs Wade was
overturned
Dr Doug lob is the former president of
the American College of Obstetricians
and gynecologists he has spent half a
century fighting for women's rights and
he's my mentor Dr lob is moving his
Wisconsin abortion practice over the
state border to neighboring Rockford
Illinois where abortion is legal he goes
down to Rockford with me all the time
Jeannie Bissell is in charge of
fundraising and will help lob run the
clinic located in a former Veterinary
Clinic the two take us on a trip
an hour and 15 to the new site yeah it's
all on the interstate so it's not too
bad for them but they know the trip will
be difficult for many patients I will do
whatever it takes if we if I have to
hire an ambulance to get somebody from
one of the hospitals down there if their
insurance will pay for it I'm going to
pay for it because it's unconscionable
when the dogs decision came down what
was that like for you the patients that
were waiting in the waiting room had to
be canceled they had already driven the
two or three hours to our clinic and to
the one in Milwaukee
and then had to be canceled it was a
very a joyful day for the pro-life
movement but also a wake-up call because
now our our true work begins when door
knocking in support of Republican
candidates for the midterms Gracie
stogman doesn't identify herself as part
of the anti-abortion movement we
actually aren't specifically talking
about pro-life issues when we're talking
to voters because it's so controversial
I mean if they ask I'll say this
candidate's pro-life but normally it
doesn't come up back on the road to
Rockford the conversation turns to
politics and the importance of keeping
Democratic Wisconsin governor Tony Evers
in office he is vetoed between 35 and 40
laws that were designed by the
Republicans to inhibit access
to abortion we need to keep him in
office we need to keep our attorney
general in our office
they'll get buzzed in and this is a
security vestibule then they'll get
buzzed in again with the receptionists
the fight for Reproductive Rights is
also being fought along Illinois
Southern border with Missouri in a more
mobile way it looks very much like a
regular brick and mortar Health Center
for us this clinic will be accessible to
those coming from out of state the plan
is to provide medical abortions by Pill
by the end of the year and surgical
procedures next year we need folks to be
thinking differently to be working
together to be acting boldly and to be
taking risks the clinic also comes with
a security guard and back in Rockford
they're also taking precautions and
you've already had protesters come here
yeah yes and they had to call the police
not even open yet because no matter
where these clinics move those running
them will have to take extra measures to
give women basic Medical Care they've
come to expect for 50 years and many
hope will return
coming up Putin's wartime winter
strategy is colder weather nears
if Republicans in the U.S take control
of the House of Representatives and the
Senate there are fears Aid being
delivered to Ukraine could dry up and
that couldn't come at a worse time for
the many ukrainians still at risk from
Vladimir Putin's Invasion right now
Russian attacks are targeting Ukraine's
energy infrastructure knocking out power
grids and that's leaving millions of
people helpless without heat as freezing
winter fast approaches Ross Lord has
more on the desperate situation in the
eastern Ukraine town of seversk
collecting firewood is becoming a matter
of life and death for retiree Valentina
kazakova
it's a terrible situation she says how
could it be anything but terrible
her apartment building is destroyed she
and her husband have lived in the
basement since July with no power no
water and no gas
there's a lot of shelling noises she
says every time her heart freezes and
she waits
continual mortar fire and widespread
Devastation and with Russian attacks
disabling ever more power grids and
water infrastructure energy providers
are using planned power cuts to avoid
overloads and allow repairs leaders in
regions enduring power blackouts
including Kiev are warning residents to
prepare for the worst with the onset of
winter later this month
key of Mayor Vitali Klitschko says in
the event of a total blackout residents
should consider moving to emergency
lodging with friends and family who live
elsewhere and have control of their
water and heating supply the Russian
effort to break the will of ukrainians
by depriving them of life's Essentials
is an age-old tactic used in many
previous conflicts a development that's
causing military analysts to re-evaluate
the Russian invasion yes this could lead
to cities going dark in Ukraine where we
can send generators we can allow Ukraine
to take back more territory this will
send a message to the Russian military
that this their situation is not
encouraging that Russia ultimately will
lose this conflict Brown calls the
Russian tactic energy terrorism he says
Canada and other allies need to step up
supplies and support to Ukraine to
ensure Vladimir Putin fails
Ross Lord Global News
[Music]
had the U.N climate Summit cop 27 opens
with a stark warning
a new study from the United Nations
shows the last eight years were the
hottest on record the report by the un's
World Meteorological organization also
States the Paris agreement's 1.5 degrees
Celsius limit for Global heating is now
barely within reach the U.N Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez calls the
report a Chronicle of climate chaos and
that change is happening with
catastrophic speed it also comes as
world leaders and delegates gather for
the cop 27 climate Summit in Egypt as
many major countries are still falling
short on their climate goals
in Tanzania at least 19 people are dead
after a commercial flight crashed into
Lake Victoria near the city of bukoba
the plane operated by precision air
plunged into the water it was
approaching the airport bystanders and
fishermen watched it unfold and tried to
get to the scene to help officials
believe all bodies have been recovered
from the aircraft with 26 people being
treated for injuries at nearby hospitals
no details on the cause of the crash
[Music]
next we'll rejoin Donna in Washington
while the Democrats say the future of
American democracy is on the ballot
[Music]
welcome back to global national we are
in Washington ahead of this week's
midterm elections in the last two
decades democracy has been on
increasingly Shaky Ground in Russia
turkey Venezuela India Hungary and
Poland leaders to varying degrees have
sought to subvert institutions and the
rule of law silence critics and
consolidate their own rule democracy is
even under threat in the place where it
was thought to be well established here
in the United States the promise of a
golden future and that only one man and
it always seems to be a man can deliver
it is an appealing notion at a time when
growing inequality has fueled
uncertainty and anger and elected
leaders have largely failed to address
it add to that the spread of lies about
voter fraud and a stolen election and
you get a potent mix infecting this
country
the Lincoln Memorial 100 years old this
year stands as an imposing tribute to an
assassinated President the man who saved
the union immortalized in Marble a
symbol of unity strength and wisdom
what would he make of America today
there's no such thing as election
denying in a free Society it's called
Free Speech you're allowed to say it if
you think it period and they are saying
it Republican Kerry lake is running to
be Arizona governor the truth is Joe
Biden did not win with 81 million votes
and it and if you believe he did then
you are the conspiracy theorist
the truth is Biden did win and all 50
States including the Republican ones
certified the 2020 election but it's
2022 not only is the notion of objective
truth shredded democracy itself seems to
be in Peril listen to this conservative
talk show host democracy is a bad idea
and so it has come to this a former
president campaigning to save democracy
and facts
and logic
and reason
and basic decency are on the ballot
democracy itself is on the ballot a poll
conducted in October by Associated Press
and the University of Chicago found only
nine percent of adults believe democracy
is working extremely or very well 52
percent feel it's not working well we're
facing a defining moment
an inflection point we know democracy at
risk is at risk but we also know this
is within our power
each and every one of us to preserve our
democracy Freedom housed which monitors
democracy and rule of law globally found
2021 was the 16th consecutive year of
decline in global freedom and now this
man is positioning himself for a
comeback promising only he can save
America look at all of them they must
think I'm going to announce for
president tonight that's that's a lot
democracy though depends on the power of
the people not on one man and not on
lies violence and attempted Insurrection
the attack on the U.S capital failed in
2021
the ideals this country was built on
prevailed as the great memorials remind
us even if they stand on increasingly
Shaky Ground
and that is global national for this
Sunday from the American capital
Washington D.C I'll see you back here
tomorrow for Farah NASA and myself
thanks for watching bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]